there are products available that you
can buy we're ready available in auto
stores etc the contain anesthetic gas
and those could be used as I understand
it they it's used for example they break
into the villa first of all and then
they will pump the gas into the master
bedroom or other bedrooms if there's
other guests wait a while and then when
they enter the room the gas is already
dispersed but it's had the effect on the
occupants I have spoken to people that
have been guests so yes it definitely
does happen when you spoke say smoke
people who have been gassed how
prevalent is it in the south of France
um it's something that does go on it's
not every day but it's a regular
occurrence um a couple of years ago
there was a famous footballer who was
gassed in Valerie's you got Jenson
Button in San Tropez you know the
clients i'm thinking of worrying
villefranche so spread all across the
south of France but actually being able
to enter a building like that and pump
the gas in or indeed introduce it
through the air conditioning system is
that possible without someone waking up
well an air conditioning system isn't
only a closed circuit so it wouldn't be
introduced by that system an unpaid room
we know it depends on the villa and the
property if the reason I get called is
because people haven't got an alarm or
it was ineffective or they know they
didn't switch it on and if that's the
case then obviously somebody can get in
they can and they can I introduce the
gas into the room but an alarm in this
particular situation how useful is it
because you've got occupants inside the
villa already so surely they could set
it off by moving around no no the way
you set up a system like that the the
users can within the villa to move
around freely
you put a first perimeter warning
perimeter alarm in so that before
they've been approached a bit before
they could even try and attack anything
on the villa you've got an alarm that
goes off should should they get past
that somehow you've then got the theory
of the villa alarmed and as soon as that
you try and open any access point the
alarm goes off you know it's a very
effective way Oh clearly if what we're
seeing here is a burglary in which
gassing has taken place it's taken some
preparation and surely the burglars
concerned will have had a scope out the
joint beforehand so what do you advise
clients what should they be looking out
for people turning up that haven't been
invited you know knock on the door with
the EDF we need to see your your meter
or things like this no no one in France
will turn up without her legitimately
will turn up without having sent a
letter in advance so in general if you
get somebody knock on your door just
send them away and how seriously are
these kind of attacks taken by police'
yeah that I can't really answer you'd
have to just feature them so you
couldn't I something for example how
easy to detect you know if you've had a
burglary this thought is it easier as it
harder touch to find out yes the general
generally they know it because they'll
wake up with a bad headache so that's
that's that's the only sign I have heard
of people having blood test to find out
if they've been guests and what's been
used so that can also be done and that
would be done at there yeah the police
can suggest that that stunning you go to
doctor and have the blood test done but
would need to be done fairly quickly and
there are gas detectors that we install
so somebody does try to introduce a gas
into the house you know that will pick
it up and set off an alarm straightaway
how many of those do you install gas
detectors because it's not so it's not
the kind of crime you think about when
you think about the south of France know
what tends to happen as I say is there
will be a high-profile incident like
this
and then we'll have a lot of demand for
a year or two and then that will drop
off again and then there be another big
incident and it'll you know everybody be
calling me